if I work abroad my abilities can be
expanded unlike here
Healthcare Systems around the world are
experiencing a nurse shortage as many
protest low wages and long hours others
threatening to quit after years of
working under the pandemic
that means governments are competing to
attract Talent from countries like the
Philippines the world's largest exporter
of nurses
Elaine Torres is one of thousands of
young Filipinos responding to the calls
she juggles a six-hour commute six days
a week to attend nursing school with the
dream of working overseas for a better
pay and lifestyle I decided to General
in nursing school since last year 2021
I'm considering job overseas I'm looking
forward for working in New Zealand the
shortage for nurses is on track to more
than double from pre-pandemic levels to
reach 13 million people globally
countries are implementing initiatives
to welcome foreign workers as quickly as
possible Germany aims to recruit
Filipino nurses by offering to pay for
travel expenses language training and
helping find accommodation
Australia is increasing its skilled
migrant cap by 35
000 to 195 000 workers which includes
nurses
there's a lot of changes for needed for
me to work here in the Philippines
Healthcare System here and it's not as
good as some other countries the
Philippines issued more than 11 000
nursing licenses last year but it's
still far from making up the potential
shortage of 13 million
[Music]